begins in pittsburgh where it wasn't
clear in the immediate aftermath over
the steelers win over the colts whether
or not they would
give some of their key players the bye
week that they never
got this year because as you'll remember
week four
they practiced and prepared to face the
titans that game got pushed back
three weeks to their bye week and then
the steelers spent their bye week
practicing and preparing and ultimately
playing
and then they've had their schedule
screwed around and bumped around and
moved around and it was always someone
else's
fault but they had to deal with the
aftermath now the browns will be dealing
in a good way with the fact that the
steelers are planning to
rest key starters including quarterback
ben roethlisberger which means
mason rudolph shereen as you said
yesterday will start against the browns
and miles garrett here is mike tomlin
from earlier today
explaining his decision to reporters
the one buy available in this in this
single elimination tournament um
you know we're not going to be that team
we made that bid so we're prepared to
lay in it
that's the most significant variable for
us and so that being said
uh given an opportunity to airmail a
player or two to the postseason
we will uh ben will not be playing this
week
we'll turn toward mason rudolph and our
young quarterback positional group
and give those guys an opportunity um
we'll look potentially
arresting some other guys in terms of
making them inactive but the number of
those guys and who those guys are
will be determined as we push through
the week make no mistake about it
um it does not change our intentions in
terms of going to cleveland this weekend
football is our game our job is winning
we intend to do our job
we intend to prepare with that mindset
and ultimately let our play lead us to
that destination
um we're not seeking comfort we're not
grading ourselves on the curve
this game is on the schedule and so the
guys will be on the field will represent
us
in the standard that is the pittsburgh
steelers will be the standard
well yes it will be the standard but we
saw last year what happens when ben
roethlisberger doesn't play mason
rudolph was not good duck hodges was not
good although compared to mason rude off
doc hodges was pretty good
and now mason rudolph gets a chance to
try to
show people that by not playing this
year practicing learning studying
whatever he's gotten better the steelers
do not need the game the browns
desperately do it is a gift to the
browns
and i always say you want to keep
division rivals out of the playoffs if
you can although between the browns and
the ravens i think the steelers
would be better off keeping the ravens
out if they could not the browns
the steelers can deal with the browns a
lot more easily than they could deal
with the ravens
what do you think though is this the
right move for the steelers to
consciously take the foot off the gas
when there's still a chance
in theory to finish the number two seed
well one thing mike that that has gone
unnoticed in all this
is the change where only the top seed
gets the buy this year so
if this was last year or the year before
or whatever the steerers should be
playing their starters this week because
they would want to
try to get that two seed to get the bye
week and then they would have their
quote unquote by next week right but
they can't do that with the change to
the playoff format only one team gets
that and that's going to be the chiefs
this year so
they can rest their starters and i get
why they're doing it i mean ben
roethlisberger has been banged up
there's no question about that they
didn't get their bye week as you said
they've had a long stretch here and
they've talked a lot about being
mentally
and physically tired so i get why
they're doing it
at the same time this is a football team
that has not played good except for one
half over the last four games and that
was the last half that they played
can they take this week off and then
continue what they did in the second
half against the colts
i don't know if they can do that or not
i do have some questions about
how they've gotten back to where they
are now and if they can get back to that
11-0
stretch the way they were playing
especially with all the defensive
starters that they've lost mike
it's a tough call i get it if i'm if i
am mike tomlin i probably rest ben
roethlisberger for sure this week but i
do go out and try to win this game to
try to keep the momentum going
yeah there's been this nagging question
about whether and to what extent ben
roethlisberger is injured there will be
reports from time to time typically of
the sunday splash variety
that suggest roethlisberger has knee
problems you look at the injury reports
no mention of any knee problems in
recent weeks
not since week 13 was he disclosed as
having a knee issue
so it's unclear whether and to what
extent he is healthy he has recently
said
he's not a hundred percent but at this
time of the year no one is the rest
though i think
will help him it definitely can hurt him
and as travis kelsey the chief's head
and told me
on sunday after they clinched the number
one seed in beating the atlanta falcons
17-14
it's not a week off it's a different
week you don't play a game
but you still practice you work on your
body you work on your weaknesses you
prepare for your next opponent you think
about other things
than playing a team that coming sunday
or saturday as the case may be in the
wild card round
but still it's a break from
the grind the week in and week out
knowing you've got a game coming up and
in the wild card round obviously it's a
game that could knock you out of the
playoffs for the steelers
there's no downside to losing this game
other than being the three seed but i
will say this
if it does come down to divisional round
steelers
bills you'd rather the bills come to
pittsburgh
then have to go to buffalo to play the
bills but as mike tomlin
weighs the various factors in his mind
because the bills also would have to
lose and the steelers would have to win
and maybe you're out there burning up
more of whatever
ben rothersberger has left in the tank
and wasting it
because the bills beat the dolphins he
decides that it's better to just say
we'll go to buffalo if we have to go to
buffalo
and uh we won't bring them here and and
this reminds me of something tj watt
told me after the game this past sunday
the idea that it's not the same in
pittsburgh and they haven't gotten used
to
not having fans there they have to find
their own energy week in and week out
maybe they can feed off of the negative
energy that the 6700 fans if that plan
is approved in buffalo
will be throwing down to the field as
the steelers and the bills get ready to
play so
i understand why tomlin is doing it
because in large part of the fact that
they've had this screwy upside down
schedule and if it means conceding
the two seed to the bills so be it in
any other year
or in any past year when it would mean
something like you said or in any future
year
where having home field advantage means
something more
because you're playing those games in
front of fans i would say go for it this
year i can understand why he's
why he's not doing it especially because
ben roethlisberger has been so ricky
sharin i i am curious to see how many
other guys
end up getting that game off the defense
seemingly needs the rest more than the
rest of the offense if anything the rest
of the offense needs the work
yeah that's exactly right mike and that
defense has been banged up and you would
think they might rest the likes of
tj white and some of those guys who've
who really
been banged around this season and i'm
curious too if this prompts the buffalo
bills
now to to take a rest week for
some of their starters knowing that the
steelers are going to be doing the same
thing i know they've said repeatedly
they're going to play to win but
knowing that the steelers are going to
arrest some of their starters maybe this
changes
what sean mcdermott wants to do this
week against the dolphins but this could
completely change
mike how the wild card race turns out
if the colts end up playing all their
starters and the steelers don't
it could completely change how this
thing unfolds for these teams fighting
for the wild card
bursts well and that's right and look i
look at the bills right now and they
are in this mode where they are trying
to prove themselves
week in and week out and they're trying
to convince themselves
more themselves than anyone else that
they are an elite team
and when you look at their last four
games and really the last five dating
back to the buy i wrote something
earlier today about comments from bill
safety micah hyde regarding what the
hale murray did
for them and since the bye week which
immediately came
after the hail murray loss to the
cardinals
it's been double-digit win after
double-digit win and the margin the last
two weeks
86 i believe to 28
between the win over the broncos and the
win over the patriots
they are proving to the world and
themselves that they are one of those
special teams that they are peaking at
the right time
i don't know that you'll want to
consciously
give that up in exchange for some rest
that your team by all appearances
doesn't seem to need
keep the momentum rolling and also take
advantage the opportunity
to knock the dolphins out of the
playoffs because
you typically don't want to face a
division rival
in a winner take all win or go home
type of a setting because a division
rival is not going to be afraid of you
intimidated by you and they're going to
relish the chance to come into your
building
and end your season if they can one
thing about the browns as they try to go
forward with
avoiding a 10-6 finish to the season
that would knock them
out of the playoffs like in 2007 titan
harrison bryant
safety andrew sendejo placed on the
reserve covet 19
list earlier this afternoon not clear
whether that means they tested positive
we had the rash of close contacts over
the weekend
not good for the browns though if it is
a sign shireen of some sort of
lingering problem that is popping up
positives
days after the fact as the incubation
period continues to
hit different guys who have gotten it
and then as they shed virus
before they're removed from the
population they can expose
other guys to it so this is going to be
something that the browns
should be worried about all week long
absolutely mike and they saw what
happened last week when they were
without a receiving core they had one
receiver off the active roster and
lost the jets and that played a big part
in that loss or they'd
already be in the playoffs and they're
not there and now they're faced with a
must-win
game when they may be missing some other
key players
this week but you've got to go on and
play with the cards you're dealt and
this is what they're dealt with and then
go beat the steelers without
ben roethlisberger and assure themselves
a playoff berth and that's what it's
going to take it's going to take beating
mason rudolph this week and
you know what if you can't beat the jets
and or
the mason rudolph you don't deserve to
go to the playoffs
i was just formulating that same thought
if you can't beat mason rudolph
with a postseason berth on the line then
baker mayfield
and the browns aren't ready to go to the
postseason and i understand what
happened last week it was a strange
curveball although we've known all year
that any given team in every given week
could face that kind of a curveball
it's still hard to process it this week
unless a bunch of guys end up
unavailable
without enough time to adjust the browns
should be able to beat the steelers if
mason rudolph is playing quarterback
unless he has discovered some untapped
reservoir of football
ability and talent that we previously
have not witnessed
all due respect to mason rudolph
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports